dès dimanche soir des fidèles de
beaucoup de gens en france et surtout
d'hélène ségara ici voilà il est la
touche et le hélène touché le voilà elle
a deux idoles dans sa vie c'est orlando
et voudront voilà alors c'est vous qui
l'avez eue c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée
du nom depeche mode
infos sur malheureusement oui c'est moi
alors c'est le nom d'un magazine de mode
français pourquoi pas elles ou marie
claire oui effectivement on aurait pu
prendre les autres j'étais écolier à
l'époque j'ai j'ai étudié en fait la
mode et on allait faire écran certes un
petit concert dans un pub à londres et
puis nous n'avons pas encore de nom il y
avait ces magazines devant nous l'a été
et puis le team demander quel est le nom
du groupe
c'est le premier magazine que j'ai pris
j'ai dit et je le verrais que c'est
peut-être nul marie claire quand même
alors dbh mode c'était des pionniers
vous avez été les premiers à rendre
populaire la musique électronique
kraftwerk avant vous avait initié la
musique électronique mais il l'avait
fait d'une façon très robotique et vous
d'une façon beaucoup plus acoustique
beaucoup plus facile pour le public on
peut dire oui c'est vrai que nous avons
repris un peu de ces éléments et autres
ont été composés faire du bruit à partir
d'autre chose qu'une guitare la batterie
à propos le titre a de très bons
guitaristes ses synthétiseurs et tout ça
nous ont permis de manipuler le sont de
manière intéressante
voilà alors l'année de l'apogée de
depeche mode le climax du groupe comme
on dit c'est 1988 en 1987 vous aviez
sorti un album qui s'appelait music for
my 6 music pour les masses
ensuite il ya une tournée qui s'appelait
tort formé six tournées pour les masses
vous avez acquis à ce moment là une
célébrité mondiale île le 101e concerts
de cette tournée qui était live at the
rose bowl a été filmée par pennebaker et
il sort en dvd avec des interviews des
membres du
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
ben baker il est célèbre pour un film
qui s'appelle monterey pop qui l'a fait
en 1967 qui était un film sur la grande
époque baba il n'avait jamais entendu
parler de depeche mode quand on lui a
proposé de faire un film sur le groupe
et puis il a commencé à s'y coller il a
été fasciné par vous et par vos fans
il vous a suivi dans une tournée aux
états unis et il a filmé le 101ème
concert à rose bowl donc été un peu le
climax l'apothéose du groupe on peut
dire non en fait c'était surtout un
documentaire sur les femmes puissent les
gens qui lui sied plutôt que sur nous
mêmes et ce qui était intéressant c'est
de voir justement toute cette
accumulation ces gens qui venaient nous
voir que des fidèles à l'église
pratiquement qui nous suivait à travers
le pays c'est ça qu'il a voulu montrer
dans son rythme heurté h pense pas que
les gens bien pris la chose au monde du
documentaire des raisons on l'a critiqué
pour ça mais c'est justement de 500m
film du cash me parlez plus de 5 e de
depeche mode c'était un truc qui
s'intéressait à ses fruits dès que le
public se faisaient qu'à partir de rien
il y avait ce tte eu cette machine à on
avait créé ce truc énorme okabe la
publicité la radio mais rien d'autre
et ça c'était intéressant bruno on
disait qu'ils ont été gavés de la
superclasse de look dans son phrasé non
c'est plus efficace que l'accent texan
oui ça c'est clair mais mais mais mais
il ya une classe folle pas ce type avait
vu mieux j'habite à tous les jeunes qui
le voient pas en vrai je trouvais encore
mais enfin il est trop vieux pour rien
est fait en attaque il ya pas de
problème est jeune et vivant dans pas
longtemps et la quatrième voie alors
vous devez gamme vous étiez la voix de
depeche mode donc pendant 22 ans et vous
avez sorti en mai dernier un album solo
qui s'appelle peppers monsters
il faut que je touche qui est écrit par
ménage ou alors que généralement les
morceaux ont été écrits par martin gore
alors j'en avais un peu marre d'ailleurs
de l'hégémonie de martin gore chaussures
le groupe depeche mode
vous avez marre d'être seulement une
voie d'être seulement la voix du groupe
et vos idées de chansons étaient
rarement présent en considération dans
le groupe un petit peu comme george
harrison dans les beatles d'une certaine
façon c'est pas si la comparaison est
juste en disant qu'il y avait un peu de
ça quand même
sauf que j'en ai un petit peu assez de
voir que nous avions créé pour nous même
quand on a passé suffisamment d'années
dans le tuf après les choses et de voir
que finalement les rôles sont presque
stéréotypé et que sur le plan créatif
finalement donné ses yeux rien de
nouveau parce que nous étions cantonnés
à ce qu'on sorte à l'étiquette que nous
étions donné effectivement j'avais écrit
des chansons et puis je me suis dit que
déjà depeche mode existé et elle est
toujours être là il fallait que ça soit
avec d'autres personnes autour 1 600
pandas mais jeter un défi abonnés et
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir la peau
cazouls de faire oui vous avez bien un
petit peu marre d'être utilisée comme un
instrument votre voie utilisée comme un
instrument par le groupe
alors vous avez déclaré d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui l'avenir du groupe depeche
mode dépend de l'attitude de martin gore
parce que on a compris
ils vous laissent pas place et plus de
chansons avoue on se dirige vers le
split en ces termes là mais j'ai vu
partir tout récemment à los angeles j'ai
vu un homme de mes concerts elle a
trouvé ça bien je n'a pas parler
tellement de depeche mode
il me semble que maintenant je me suis
ouvert une porte un modèle et j'ai
beaucoup aimé ce que j'ai vu cette part
j'aime beaucoup mon groupe nous allons
bientôt jouer ensemble et je peux pas je
peux plus revenir en arrière donc aussi
je continue à aller de l'avant à la
musique et bien sûr des clous je ferai
la musique est prêt à se partageront sa
destinée en qu'est ce que ça fait des
années que j'ai voulu participer au
groupe et je suis fier de sa carrière
cette dépêche mode mais aussi l'appui de
groupes alors l'album s'appelle peppers
monsters et monstres de papier ces
monstres de papier dont vous parlez en
fait vous dites que c'est des monstres
que vous vous étiez créer vous même
c'est la drogue et l'alcool
et vous aussi comme pierre botton vous
êtes guéri je ne sais pas si je suis
guéri je crois pas qu'on puisse répond
thierry il ya vraiment de guérison à
guérison mais disons que j'ai beaucoup
changé de choses dans ma vie c'est de
cette façon je crois qu'on peut dire que
disons que je peux m'identifier un petit
peu monsieur bouton page est appliquée
beaucoup de sous donc les monstres oui
je parle surtout des déclins des
angoisses et le fait de pouvoir de
pouvoir faire face à ses angoisses et de
faire des choses qu'on n'aurait pas fait
parce qu'on a créé justement des
monstres au soi même on se cache
derrière ces bons seront ma tendance à
se cacher derrière ça et puis un jour il
faut quand même dépasser cela alors
votre vie est différente maintenant vous
lever tôt
vous accompagnez votre fils à l'école
vous faites de la gymnastique vous fait
du jogging
mes deux fils
vous faites des exercices vocaux enfin
tout ce à quoi est-ce que vous savez
c'est bien c'est bien parce qu'en plus
je vais vous dire vous avez quand même
je pense que vous avez pris je sais pas
quelle quantité vous avez pris de drogue
et d'alcool dans tous les cas vous êtes
vachement bien des biens concernés sans
courage est drogué ça arrive et je signe
ça c'est le seul problème de ces groupes
dans les années 80 ainsi qu'ils ont pas
vécu comme les z deep purple un la
grosse défoncé galets grosse d'un gris
et finalement je m'aperçois qu'il a vécu
la même chose mais il s'en tire super
mais les quadragénaires c'est un bel âge
pour un homme en baskets ou tu connais
les quadragénaires c'est un vieux joue
pas parce que j'étais des quadragénaires
you volume one 41 pas là bas ils
hériteraient à une époque quand même
vous vous aviez un ange gardien avec
vous qui s'appelait aident et qui était
un ancien bar un ancien drogué qui vous
suivait partout et c est ce que vous
l'avez toujours non j'ai parlé récemment
être non habite à detroit
dans le michigan avec moi une fois mais
pas tous parti depuis que c'est
quelqu'un de bien surtout quand je suis
retourné pas si c'est pas mal de trappes
d'avoir un copain l'aixois des choses
hélène ségara je connais pas hélène
ségara when she was here she wolf
mais orlando lui a demandé de chanter
autre chose que du depeche mode wrong
mais en plus il avait un vrai look
tu vois il s'appelle pas comme ça par
hasard ils ont un mode survival des
années 80 et de tout ce qu'ils ont
emporté tout cas on va y voit la mort
nom des factions
qu'est ce que tu fais et lucas tu fais
un char mais j'ai dit c'est parce que il
ya ma fille m'a demandé de dessiner un
chat alors j'ai dit darche à qui ce qui
se shootent avec une farine dans
laquelle il ya des souris 1 c'est bien
ça durera pas et ça peut dire à passer
dans l'aiguillé c'est bien en tous les
cas en parlant de sa dette gagnent quand
vous repensez maintenant à cette époque
c'est-à-dire à los angeles quand vous
vous étiez lacéré les poignets avec une
lame de rasoir
quand vous pensez à l'overdose que vous
avez fait au speed ball au sunset
marquis hôtel à berlin
je me rappelle pas tout ça mais enfin
quand vous pensez à ça aujourd'hui à
cette époque de c'était partie de mon
parcours de ma ville c'est ce que je
peux dire c'étaient des choix que
j'avais fait à l'époque quand on en fait
trop
comme pour tout bon c'est vrai que vous
êtes mort pendant c'est vrai que vous
êtes mort pendant deux minutes quand
vous avez fait cette overdose autres 67
marque effectivement je crois que
j'étais
on m'a emmené à l'hosto je crois que je
fais le home a dit ça après coup
effectivement je ne le savais pas sur le
moment c'est ce genre d'histoire un
petit peu rasoir mais je me rendais
comme je faisais je me disais mais c'est
débile mais il a fallu que j'arrive à ce
stade là pour me rendre compte de la
bêtise à ce que je faisais je me rendais
compte que c'était débile et jusque là
je crois que je m'amusais mais c'était
pas c'était pas très bien est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez dire aux
gens qui vous regardent aux gens qui
nous regardent que la drogue c'est sympa
au départ qu'on en prend pour être bien
et puis qu au bout d'un mois deux mois
trois mois on en prend juste pour pas
être mal et que ça devient un enfer
quand on rencontre des problèmes avec
l'alcool
y a pas su faire la différence la drogue
qui ont parlé des choses qui paraissent
acceptables au départ et puis qui
entraîne des problèmes par la suite
justement à cause des excès et chez je
me suis battu publiquement contre la
drogue ce beau combat était publique et
et j'ai voulu effectivement l'aide du
public dans tout ce que je peux espérer
c'est que aujourd'hui moi même je puisse
faire quelque chose de positif par
rapport à tout ça j'ai la chance de
pouvoir être au cola à faire de la
musique c'est la raison pour laquelle je
me suis lancé là dedans au départ j'ai
la chance d'avoir eu une deuxième chance
de m'en sortir je crois qu'il faut
pouvoir demander de l'aide
quelqu'un je crois que c'est la chose la
plus difficile on viendra c'est moi j'ai
eu la chance d'abord autour de moi des
gens qui travaillaient pour voir avec
moi quelques vrais amis mon manager joe
dalton qui là aussi qui m'a aidé les
pointures de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu